the Supreme Court also ruled that
President Biden is not allowed to wipe
out hundreds of billions and perhaps
trillions of dollars in student loan
debt which would have been very unfair
to the millions and millions of people
who paid their debt through hard work
and diligence very unfair but this was a
way of trying to buy votes that's all it
was
[Music]
former president Trump applauding the
Supreme Court for being a check to the
vast overreach of the bite
Administration Friday's six to three
ruling struck down bidens of 400 billion
dollar student loan bailout the majority
opinion said it was a clear Act of
executive overreach and quoted former
speaker Nancy Pelosi taking that exact
same position in the past but Biden
claimed the six justices were wrong when
asked whether he overreached
did you overstep your
people I think the court misinterpreted
the Constitution
President Biden is now planning to try
again using what's called The Higher
Education Act which he claims will allow
the education secretary to waive or
release loans under certain
circumstances it's likely to face the
same legal challenges as his original
bailout plan for more on this let's
bring in Florida attorney general Ashley
Moody uh General Moody thanks so much
for joining us on Sunday morning Futures
do appreciate it look two big big cases
at the end of the courts session here
let's tackle uh the the education
bailout the bailout of the student loans
what's your take on that
well look you know the United States has
the world's leading amount of debt I
mean we're standing at about 31 trillion
so to have a president that comes in and
wants to unilaterally put 400 billion
extra on taxpayers
is incredible it was a major power grab
it has always been the law of the nation
that these major questions of Economic
Policy are decided by Congress
the president and its unelected agencies
have no ability no lawful right to come
in and make these kinds of decisions so
you know this is a major separation of
powers issue and to have a president of
the United States even suggest that the
Supreme Court misinterpreted this this
was an easy one and I love you know when
you have leaders that come out and say
this is such a snow job by these by
President Biden trying to say he's
trying to help hard-working Americans
exactly the opposite they were trying to
push all this debt all this expense 400
billion on hard-working Americans so I
love it when you have folks come out and
call them out on that the narratives
they try to spend are just unbelievable
sometimes
yeah it is amazing to think that the
Biden Administration thinks it's okay to
take somebody else's loan and make you
pay for it that's what's absurd about
all this and you can't just wipe out 400
billion dollars I think the justices did
get the right get it right in this case
another landmark case which will affect
residents in your state in every state
has to do with affirmative action the
idea that maybe uh Merit should be the
primary focus on how you select your
next students rather than some
affirmative action plan what was your
take on that Supreme Court ruling well
you know Florida has eliminated
race-based considerations from our
University since 1999. Governor Bush was
in office and he said look I don't want
the color of someone's skin determining
about determining whether or not they
get into a university and they came up
with a method for making sure diversity
of perspective and experience and
thought was assured but not judging
people on the color of their skin and in
fact the Supreme Court came out and said
this is unlawful we are a nation that
judges people not based on the color of
the skin that's the definition of
equality in this nation and there are
ways that you can assure we have this
kind of diversity of thought and
experience like we've done in Florida
for decades without basing it on the
color of someone's skin so you know of
course this is now the ruling of the of
the land this is the law of the land but
we've been doing this in Florida for
some time
the the the Democratic left the
Democrats are really outraged about this
their their political Ploy has been one
of division and separating People based
on the color of their skin so contrary
to the comments of Martin Luther King
listen to Justice sotomayar on her take
on what was going on in this case
it's
so I I thought it was sound but she had
a quote about this she took a very
strong position on this case and you
know was chastised for getting the facts
wrong the six unelected members of
today's majority up and the status quo
based on their policy preferences about
what race in America should be like but
is not
I absolutely disagree with the statement
in fact justices came out and said when
we are judging people let's look at the
experiences they have gone through how
have they shown and demonstrated courage
determination the ability to overcome
adversity we can consider those things
without saying and recognizing that we
should judge them on the color of their
skin I mean look at the hardships people
have overcome that can be considered and
that can be applied to people of all
skin colors and so I think that this is
a a decision that will move our
universities in a direction of judging
people by the merits and maybe that
includes the the odds that they have
overcome the the circumstances that they
have had to face head on and fight
through to apply for admission and that
would be available to every person
regardless of skin color so I think if
you read through this decision people
will see that the the justices
understand stood the need for diversity
of thought and experience and
perspective and this ruling is not
contrary to that
I want to shift gears with you because
Florida just did something interesting
it became law yesterday putting more
requirements in terms of offering
identification for certain Services I
happen to think everybody should have to
show an ID for voting an election the
crazy me for thinking that but explain
what this law did in Florida to tighten
up on illegal immigration
well as you have seen especially during
the disastrous Biden Administration when
it comes to immigration the states have
had to Bear enormous costs and
challenges as it relates to our criminal
justice system from this radical open
border policy and Florida is trying to
pass legislation to deal with that
within the bounds that we can of course
the the federal government is not doing
its job as not following the law and so
a lot is left on the state so for
example one of our our laws now we have
to determine who is coming into our
hospital system how we are are managing
these costs is this for Citizens that
are paying taxes is this for people that
are here illegally we have to account
for numbers that are coming through our
criminal justice system and our laws are
now designed to identify and account for
that as you know many of my challenges
in courts that have been successful
we've had to show standing how is this
policy of affecting Florida and many
times it's hard to do because a lot of
this has been done under cover of night
it's been done with a lot of smoke and
mirrors in fact a lot of what's
Happening Now a lot of their bragging
about numbers going down look numbers
are not going down this is an a
laundering scheme by the Biden
Administration to shift how they're
counting numbers and the states are
trying to address how this is going to
impact them so I believe you'll see a
lot of states start following Florida's
lead and passing legislation to try and
get their hands around the data and
understand what's happening how their
states are being affected
yeah Congressman Mark green out of Texas
are out of Tennessee I should say has
stated that there was a three-fold
increase in the number of Chinese
Nationals crossing our borders uh in
fiscal two uh 2023 10
000 Chinese Nationals apprehended on our
border trying to come across our border
it's not just a problem with Central and
South America it is a global problem
glad to see Florida has actually taken
some action and putting in new new laws
in place to try to fight back against
that uh Florida attorney general Ashley
Moody thank you so much for joining us
on Sunday morning Futures do appreciate
it great to be with you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else